wouldn't that post voice be at least a
little muffled behind that thick mask
I'll think about that while we run down
the most fun random little [ __ ] you may
have missed in the new Deadpool -
trailer then let us know what you think
I can't really be a little harder to
fool finally we get our formal
introduction to Josh Brolin as cable a
cybernetic mutant soldier from the
future who has returned to our time on a
mission they brought over his
distinctive bionic eye but we can't be
sure just how much of his backstory has
made the transition you see in the
comics cable is the biological son of
Cyclops the x-man and a clone of Jean
Grey it's possible the movie is going to
tie all of this together we do see shots
of Deadpool in the x-mansion after all
even playing around with Professor X's
chair while he's away this could also
explain why cable has apparently
returned to our time seeking some kid
that's Julian denizen you know the kid
from Tycho ITD's 97% fresh hunt for the
wildered a boy with some kind of
destructive flame power he's even
wearing a Power suppressing collar of
some kind from the looks of it one
possible theory and the comics cable
comes to our time to find hope a young
girl that the apocalyptic Phoenix force
considers as a new host following the
death of Jean Grey aka the Dark Phoenix
Denison matches hope in terms of age if
not gender and this would explain why
he's so important for cable defined and
could even tie in with Fox's big dark
phoenix movie later this year maybe that
will retro actively explain why the
Phoenix force needed a new host or we
could just totally be guessing here
finally is Deadpool - a mutant with
regenerative powers protecting a kid
from other Evil Mutants a film length
Logan reference well maybe
and speaking of mutants as I always am
there are a ton of them in this movie we
meet the entire freakin x-force in this
thing apparently even though they don't
tell us who most of them are who's in
for some guessing Terry Crews could be
former mercenary and a high-ranking
SHIELD agent GW bridge yes it stands for
George Washington Bridge
don't be a dick about it or maybe he's
garrison Kane in the comics he was a
member of
cables mercenary team the six-pack plus
he has cybernetic arms that give him
superhuman strength
that sounds Terry Crews II he could also
be hammer or bedlam lots of character
options here for a big strong guy we do
know that this is Zazi beats from
atlanta as the assassin Domino she's an
expert marksman and also has probability
altering luck powers that sounds helpful
and how about Japanese actress Shiori
kutsuna her look and powers kinda
resemble those of the x-men psylocke a
longtime x-force member who was
previously played by Olivia Munn in
x-men apocalypse but it seems kind of
unlikely that Fox would reuse the
character already she also somewhat
resembles the new mutant squad members
surge a Japanese woman who can absorb
any nearby electricity but she's not
technically x-force hmm let me think
about that one for about an hour and get
back to you that's almost definitely
shatter star to Deadpool's right as they
exit the plane hard a mistake that
distinctive helmet and poofy hairstyle
it also kind of looks like Bill
skarsgård might be playing solo based on
the tactical gear he's the one that
looks like Pennywise the clown without
makeup because he is also yes apparently
comedian and Twitter personality Rob
Delaney also joins the team but we have
no idea which mutant he's supposed to be
still x-force right no no wait that's
the Wakanda sign they literally just
used this one and of course it wouldn't
be Deadpool without a couple of meta
references and inside jokes sorry I'm
late I was rounding up all the glueten
Deadpool tells his girlfriend that he
launched all the world's gluten into
space kiss me like you miss me read Ryan
Reynolds actually eats a gluten-free
diet when preparing to play Deadpool
it's a high protein in veggie 3,200
calorie per day diet hmm a card
reference is not one but two films
written by screenwriting icon a lean
brush McKenna 27 dresses and The Devil
Wears Prada she's often credited with
reinvigorating the romantic comedy genre
so important to mr. Reynolds his career
and she co-created CW's current hit
crazy ex-girlfriend and of course who
could miss DP Sisterhood of the
pants shout out and that is why
Sisterhood of the Traveling Pants is
pure pornography it's no wonder he finds
the movies such a turn-on mrs. Ryan
Reynolds aka Blake Lively played central
character Bridget breve real and in the
film Plus Deadpool in a coffin is this a
Ryan Reynolds buried shoutout
remember buried anyone anyone nope
alright that's it for me the host with
the mouth kill nonnamous though I know a
lot of other hosts have mouths it
doesn't set me apart look there's a
great show you should just come on back
next time
[Applause]
[Applause]